hey guys how's it going so this video is
just gonna be pretty random I was like
you know what I'm gonna turn my camera
on and I'm just gonna talk about
whatever things I happen to start
talking about mostly which is how I
entertain myself when I'm traveling and
on the road there's a thing about hotel
rooms I don't think they're very clean
there's just something about knowing
that a bunch of random strangers have
slept in this bed before I got here and
I like the pillow like it's just now
that I'm thinking about it it kind of is
really it's kind of making me a little
unsettled and I don't feel well anyway
hi why do I amuse myself the best part
about it is I can jump on this bed
because it's not my bed and I don't have
to worry about breaking it I'm really
trying my hardest just trying to keep
myself entertained well I'm out of shape
sometimes I'll raid the minibar okay
good well nobody here so aside from
jumping on the bed some of you guys told
me to play this game it's called line
play it's sort of like a Lobel who spins
game and I've been recently quite
addicted most of the time I'd rather
spend making friends in a virtual
setting but in real life it's a little
girl where she got easier I'm gonna make
her go away here
I got her all dressed up because I
wanted her to look really freaking
fabulous which tell us she does tell her
she looks great no battery I could just
jam it to this Oh freaking day I'm gonna
show you guys my bedroom but I just
redid I just bought a whole new theme
and shotty she's like you got it you've
got it bad and I'm like what if you guys
want to add me my line play game name is
IJ oh just a side note I actually
changed my name to iJustine so if you
search for iJustine you will find me you
can come to my house you can read my
diary which I just updated is when I got
this new outfit actually posted on
Instagram so you may have already seen
she's in Paris she's shopping so it
looks like she's hungry so let's come
over here grab a bite to eat do you like
that I think she did this is one of the
pre-made ones I can't be having my
friends come over and be like girl you a
hot mess I'm gonna make her take a bath
get cleaned up girl scrub-a-dub-dub I
like randomly visiting people's rooms so
when you hop into that little portal
essentially it'll take you into random
rooms and you can like clean up people's
messes which I mean normally I wouldn't
be into cleaning up messes I'm clean you
up
I don't even clean my own house but I'm
cleaning houses here what is my life
paint it up oh you're sleepy well let's
go sleep in this strange bed shall we
okay time to wake up because we're going
to Times Square
let's go peg let's freakin go I could
roll around town high five
people bring you high five let me give
you a high five you want to my friend us
right you my friend three my friends
high five high five
and we go smoke how many people are
yours I'm gonna chat I'm gonna say no
same yellow even fun little mini games
you can play too
oh god I'm not doing well
[Music]
they did pull off oh my gosh I'm so
nervous huh oh come on the backhoe that
buns eat the screen
anyway that's line play yeah I don't
know how else to entertain myself in the
hotel room let me know if you guys have
it let me know your screen names below
so that I can add you guys and I can
come visit your rooms if you guys need
any help
doing a little tidying let me know
because apparently I'm a professional
also I'm gonna be taking some ass IJ
questions for a future episode so leave
me some questions below and I will put
those in another episode I'm just
exhausted from from the tour but it's
been really fun you guys are so awesome
and so sweet and I just love getting to
actually see you guys I got some
presents today I love all of your
presents
oh this was actually pretty awesome so
Oliver came to my book signing but he
also wrote a book himself it's the
youtubers handbook for iJustine it
thanks for the inspiration I mean this
is super freaking cute this is just a
really random video and I just wanted to
say thank you guys for all of your
amazing support and everything like I
just know it's very overwhelming getting
to see you and see how much like
creating videos means to people I know
it's very strange but I love you guys
and I will see you soon and yeah thanks
for being awesome
[Music]